bonjour et bien au cours de cette
édition nous vous parlerons de la mort à
97 ans du philosophe britannique
bertrand russell philosophe et
mathématicien prix nobel 1950
bertrand russell qui était considéré
comme l'un des plus grands penseurs du
20e siècle
nous vous parlerons également des
inquiétudes soviétique à l'égard de la
situation au proche orient inquiétudes
qui viennent de donner lieu à un
important chassé croisé diplomatique
nous vous dirons un mot de la
réouverture de la faculté de droit ce
matin à nanterre en information générale
nous évoquerons notamment le crack d'une
société de promotion immobilière la
mondiale le passif provisoire est de 17
millions de francs et nous allons ouvrir
tout d'abord ce journal avec un portrait
de bertrand russell qui viennent
de la pensée mathématique à la politique
en passant par la philosophie et la
sociologie
tel fut le destin de lord battre l'aso
penseur engagé s'il en fut auteur de
plus de 50 ouvrages bertrand russell
recevait en 1950 le prix nobel de
littérature à l'âge de 78 ans loin
d'oublier qu'en 14 18 il a fait de la
prison en tant qu'objecteurs de
conscience
bertrand russell refuse de se reposer
sur ses lauriers et créé en grande
bretagne un mouvement de protestation
contre les armes nucléaires
en 1958 il écrit plusieurs livres dont
l'un a pour titre la question l'homme at
il un avenir
le philosophe illustre le mathématicien
le prix nobel a droit tous les
qualificatifs enfants terribles
personnage remuant empêcheurs de danser
en rond il n'en a cure et persiste a
dénoncé la folie des responsables
politiques et militaires et à faire
campagne auprès des grands et des moins
grands de ce monde en faveur du
désarmement
en 1963 il crée la fondation bertrand
russell pour la paix la guerre du
vietnam fait de lourdes bertrand russell
un militant acharné il sera de toutes
les grandes manifestations organisées à
londres contre la guerre au vietnam et
prendra l'initiative de créer le
tribunal pour les crimes de guerre du
vietnam tribunal que préside jean paul
sartre sa participation aux
manifestations lui vaut d'être
emprisonné à 87 ans pendant quelques
jours avec sa quatrième épouse
passionné par la défense de l'homme de
tous les hommes et de la paix engagé à
tous les niveaux bertrand russell est
aussi un philosophe sceptiques
c'est du moins ainsi qu'il apparaît dans
le troisième tome de zone autobiographie
publiée alors qu'il avait 97 ans en
ouvrant votre journal ce matin vous avez
dû remarquer un certain nombre de titres
et parmi ces titres sur lui indiquant
que l'union soviétique scène
s'inquiétaient de l'évolution de la
situation au proche-orient reverra volta
on a même parlé de menaces soviétiques
oui on a parlé de menaces soviétiques il
ya eu un démenti ce maintenant pas si
vous voulez on va recommencer on va voir
par le début il ya eu des accrochages
sérieux sur dessus du territoire
égyptien enfin il est plutôt des raids
israélien au dessus du territoire
égyptien une bataille oppose et les
syriens aux israéliens sur le plateau du
golan
l'ambassadeur du rss en france est allée
voir de monsieur georges pompidou à
l'elysée et pendant que monsieur ron
wilson recevait l'ambassadeur soviétique
en grande-bretagne aussitôt on s'est
demandé ce qui pouvait bien se passer
en fait il semble que cette double
démarche diplomatique traduisent l
inquiétude de moscou devant la menace
d'effondrement économique et militaire
de l'egypte l'egypte ne pose plus guère
de résistance aux coups de l'armée
israélienne et il semble que les crèmes
la entendait indiqué aux occidentaux les
limites au delà desquelles ce qu'il
appelle l' agression israélienne ne
serait pas toléré on disait que du côté
des états unis il n'y avait pas eu de
visite semblables d'ambassadeur
américain employait auprès du président
nixon mais monsieur malick lui ce remous
du côté de l'onu où il n'a aucune aucune
visite officielle donc du côté du
département d'état mais monsieur malik
aurait demandé que les états unis
cessent également d'encourager
l'agression sioniste en suspendant les
fournitures d'armes promise récemment
par le président nixon il s'agit
notamment de l'avion fantôme l'offensive
diplomatique soviétique mener ainsi sur
trois fronts vise évidemment à arracher
aux occidentaux des concessions dans en
attendant l'étude d'une solution
négociée pour laquelle les états unis et
l'union soviétique sont toujours
d'accord son principe du moins dans son
dernier discours son côté le président
nasser a réaffirmé sa volonté d'agir
dans le sens d'une solution pacifique
mais également de renforcer le potentiel
militaire de l'egypte pour se poser
également ce qu'il appelle la violence
terroriste d'israël
le ton général de ce dernier discours
qui a été prononcé hier soir était celui
du pessimisme quant les chances
d'aboutir à un règlement négocié en
faveur duquel le président a certes
s'est également prononcée il est vrai
sans l'afld le roi hassan ii qui se
trouve actuellement à paris
officieusement et qui a deux
nombreuses conversations avec les
dirigeants français a évoqué ce problème
notamment peut-être au cours de ce dîner
hier soir à l'elysée c'est un dîner de
40 couverts qui était offert hier à
l'élysée par le président pompidou en
l'honneur du roi du maroc
parmi les invités du côté marocain la
soeur du roi ambassadeur du maroc à rome
ses deux frères et les ministres faisant
partie de ce suite à park
du côté français on notait la présence
de monsieur maurice schumann le ministre
des affaires étrangères du premier
ministre monsieur chaban delmas du
ministre des ptt monsieur galets et du
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean de braye ce
dîner très amicale a été marquée par une
phrase du président pompidou qui
affirmait diverses vicissitudes n'ont pu
entamer l'amitié de la france et du
maroc
le dîner qui avait commencé avec 20
minutes de retard s'est terminée à 22h45
à sa sortie de l'elysée
le roi hassan ii a déclaré j'ai la
conviction que tout ira bien à nanterre
ce matin la faculté de droit a rouvert
ses portes
oui il n'y a eu aucun incident aucun
piquet de grève n'était installée à
l'entrée les cours ont repris
normalement à 9 heures des forces de
police stationne alex tiers du campus
mais elles n'ont pas eu à intervenir
puisque tout s'est bien passé pour les
dominique aury qui se fonde sur place le
téléphone est tout à l'heure pour vous
dire que l'atmosphère était me calme me
nerveuse est en fait le travail avait
repris il ya une autre information
oui c'est en présence de 900 délégués
des 950 délégué exactement des
fédérations de tous les départements
métropolitains et d'outre-mer que
s'ouvrira demain matin à nanterre
également le 19e congrès du parti
communiste que ce sera beaucoup plus
calme que la rentrée comme celles ci
soient calmes comme vous le disiez 58
délégations étrangères dans
l'organisation de résistance
palestinienne al fatah ont été invités à
participer à ce congrès qui durera
jusqu'à dimanche suivant note l'arrivée
aujourd'hui d'une délégation
tchécoslovaque
le parti communiste français n'y a plus
de contacts avec ses homologues chinois
et albanais bien ces deux pays sont
absents de cette réunion très bien nous
venons de recevoir le premier document
sur la terrible catastrophe ferroviaire
qui a fait vous le savez plus de 200
morts en argentine
le voici
236 mort 110 blessés tel est le bilan
provisoire de la catastrophe ferroviaire
survenue dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi une quarantaine de kilomètres de
buenos aires il semble que l'accident
soit dû à une panne de locomotive à 110
km/heure l'express qui venait de tout
comme en france et vers la capitale
il avait 50 minutes de retard sur son
horaire
soudain le mécanicien vie devant lui sur
la même voie un omnibus immobilisé il
était trop tard pour agir
le choc fut effroyable les tôles des
deux vallées les deux wagons se sont
littéralement imbriquées les unes dans
les autres
les obsèques des victimes de la
catastrophe auront lieu aujourd'hui le
gouvernement argentin a décrété le deuil
national pour la circonstance et secours
tentent toujours de dégager les corps
resté prisonnier de cet amas de
ferraille
à strophes la plus meurtrière de
l'histoire du rail à celle de modane qui
fit 543 mort le 12 décembre 1917 un
crack maintenant une société de
promotion immobilière lui sa société
s'appelle la mondiale installée
boulevard haussmann à paris et c'est
monsieur simon le magistrat instructeur
qui vient d'ouvrir une information
judiciaire pour banqueroute frauduleuse
à propos de la société le directeur ou
plus exactement le président directeur
général monsieur alexandre mais rennes
n'a pas donné de ses nouvelles depuis
plusieurs jours le passif est évalué à
17 millions de francs l'actuel qui est
haché provisoire on est encore à les
évaluer où il ya déjà les pour l'instant
rudolph hess est un personnage que on
oublie un peu maintenant et que ceux de
la nouvelle génération ignore
complètement et pourtant oui c'était le
dauphin de hitler il s'étend fils a
quitté l'allemagne dans les années 40 je
me souviens plus de la date exacte
d'ailleurs il a quitté l'allemagne pour
parler de paix avec les anglais les
enlever longtemps prisonnier il est
toujours en prison le 24 janvier dernier
l'ancien dignitaire nazi qui est donc
condamné à la prison à vie par le
tribunal qui a été condamné par le
tribunal international des crimes de
guerre de nuremberg avait déjà accueilli
sa famille dans sa chambre de malades
aujourd'hui il a pu recevoir la visite
de son fils le règlement interdit à sa
famille de lui serrer la main
il a quel âge il a 75 ans il ne restera
sans doute plusieurs semaines à
l'hôpital militaire britannique il
souffre d'un ulcère vous savez qu'à une
campagne qui était déclenchée en
allemagne notamment pour demander qu'il
soit libéré une autre information qui
rend prenante d'alma également à munich
oui c'est une première mondiale
semble-t-il une équipe de chirurgiens de
munich aurait réussi pour la première
fois avec succès à transplanter des
nerfs l'intervention a été pratiquée
pour la première fois sur un tourneur de
36 ans qui avait perdu 1 ère important
de l'avant bras le voici nous le voyons
actuellement à droite il s'appelle
hellmuth mitch que oui il a repris son
ancien métier l'opération a été
effectuée il ya trois mois les fonctions
motrices d'une ère sur est à nouveau
normal alors le
s'il a de particulier dans cette
technique c'est que les nerfs une fois
qu'ils ont été prélevées sur des
cadavres sont congelés est on censé
ensuite quelques mois après et le
résultat est efficace nous dans le
devoir
en sport maintenant deux combats de boxe
ea hier au palais des sports dont nous
parle maintenant l'histoire et jean
claude bouttier décocha un droit au
visage du noir cubain pedro miranda au
cours du premier rang du match vedette
hier soir au palais des sports gras
comme un moine du répertoire ayant dû
perdre plus de 2 kg en 48 heures miranda
ayant subi son premier dryden reprend le
combat mais sans réflexe n'est guère
plus dangereux cave une chine gaulle
face à boutiers affûtée par
l'entraînement américains et qu'ils
croyaient affronter un adversaire ardent
et sans réflexe la deuxième reprise
vient de commencer regardiez d'audience
moutier a vraiment de la foudre dans les
pouilles
deuxième date dans est ce là dedans on
est contestée par miranda mais il est
contée par monsieur de castellanos
l'efficacité de boutiers réel et miranda
va retourner au sol hagard les bras
ballants miranda est renvoyé dans son
coin par monsieur de castellanos et
bouttier remportent une nouvelle
victoire
le guadeloupéen roger amis champion de
france des super légers aura un
adversaire beaucoup plus conséquent en
la personne du jeune vénézuélien joliot
vieira plus grand et ayant plus dalle on
ira en culotte noire vieira accepte les
rues des échanges que lui propose élèves
de bretonne elle qui tente d'imposer le
combat de près et ne laisse aucun répit
à vieira ce dernier place des gauche à
la face et stoppe souvent les offensives
de zen la boxe variés deux amis
principalement c'est super but et
l'habileté de sa défense lui permettent
de remporter en dix reprises une très
belle victoire aux points
pourquoi pas hein ma famille arc harry
et le termineront sur l'histoire d'une
contestation qui pourrait être un peu
violente dans les tout de même pas moins
souriant la révolte gronde à et rom
petit village habituellement sans
histoire de la drôme c'est 6 124
habitants qui se partage entre la vigne
et la céramique sont unanimes
l'aménagement du rhône est une bonne
chose dit il
mais la construction du canal ne doit
pas entraîner la destruction de la
chapelle saint-antoine
or c'est justement ce qui se passe
construite par les bénédictins au 12e
siècle lieu de pèlerinage et de dévotion
cette chapelle romane n'a qu'un défaut
elle barre la route aux canards voilà
pourquoi les ouvriers qui construisent
les usines hydroélectriques le barrage
et le canal ont commencé à démonter la
chapelle en retirant les tuiles du toit
alors les habitants du village ont réagi
dimanche matin ils ont remis les tuiles
à leur place en 2h
la chapelle avait retrouvé sa toiture le
faire étant donné qu'il pleuvait par
mesure de sécurité nous avons retardé
cette opération elle dit marche matin à
7 heures tout le monde était là présent
les échelles les cordes sur 350
habitants consultés 259 se sont
prononcés pour la sauvegarde de la
chapelle et monsieur le curé
qu'en pense-t-il seul curé jeu monsieur
c'est la télévision mais une seconde
monsieur le curé
on voudrait simplement
simplement vous posez une demande vous
demander votre avis simplement non
bien sûr monsieur le curé a son idée sur
cette affaire tout comme monsieur le
maire mais ni l'un ni l'autre ne veut
pas ré avec l'indemnité versée pour la
démolition de la chapelle on pourrait
arranger l'église du village on pourrait
installer un chauffage et une horloge
électrique
pourtant à et rom personne ne peut se
résoudre à voir la chapelle engloutis
alors on propose autre chose
naturellement on n'est pas contre
l'expansion notre pays on sent très bien
que un canal en barrages dans notre
région c'est peut tirer l'industrie pour
voiliers et apporter le travail à tous
les habitants la région
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
nous ce qu'on on proposerait finalement
puisque les travaux sont trop avancé une
solution qui serait le déplacement mais
enfin ça c'est à ses nerfs et aux
techniciens de juger ou alors la
surélévation ou alors on a pensé ces
jours ci à une autre solution qui serait
peut-être la moins coûteuse
ce serait de d'enfermer la chapelle dans
une petite île est un béton armé
naturellement la muraille montré assez
haut
comparativement la hauteur de du
sanctuaire
enfin disons que ça serait la solution
la moins onéreuse
voilà maintenant je m'adresse à tous nos
amis téléspectateurs de province et
particulièrement de la campagne à 13h35
dans un tout petit moment ils vont
pouvoir regarder notre première un
format nos premières émissions
d'information agricole qui sera regroupé
sous le titre télé village alors
n'oubliez pas à 13h35 pour la première
fois t les villages pour nous c'est
terminé maintenant je vous souhaite un
bon après-midi et jean la parole à
jacques martin on va